Continental Tire Coaches Corner brings
us the Clippers head coach Doc Rivers
earlier in the show we were bringing you
the new Atlanta Atlanta Hawks jerseys
now I believe those Hawks jerseys came
out when Pete Maravich came to the Hawks
maybe a little bit before that too but
Trey young and the Hawks were that the
other day
and I like those uniforms I don't like
the ones they have now I like the back
in the 80s the Dominique Wilkins Hawks
jerseys were pretty cool and then
Maravich had those lime green uniforms
with the Atlanta Hawks but I like the
old-school Atlanta Hawks uniforms let's
bring in the former Atlanta Hawk great
Doc Rivers head coach Wow you did great
I tell you the further you get away to
better if I had a contest with all the
head coaches in the NBA just shooting
who'd win I know so I would go Steve
Kerr maybe oh yeah he was a helmet yeah
so I'm gonna I'm gonna stay with him
Popovich shoot him shoot okay it's just
like all coaches are better shooters you
know then even when they played or you
know because that's all they do that's
all we do now is just you like it's like
you wanna pop a shot yeah yeah all the
time you become pretty good at it my
Clippers are doing great I've said this
before a couple of times I sort of
looked at the Clippers in the Brooklyn
Nets and in a similar fashion that we
may not know the names but they play
hard every single night and I'm curious
how much fun are you having when you're
coaching kids and they're you got a
young team but they play hard every
night you love it you know that's one of
the things that you have to have and and
that becomes part of your talent you
know you know it's funny I think people
think that everyone's just play hard or
play
energy you know those are two different
things and and we have guys who have
that like gene in them and so that helps
but you know Pat Riley's to stay hard
and smart and I think you know hard
sometimes not good enough and though
we're young I think I guys played pretty
smart they play together and I think
that helps as well who does Patrick
Beverley remind you of anybody that you
played with or against John Stark okay
you know yeah I played with John Starks
and a very very similar trait very
similar tasks to the NBA I mean John
Starks was packing groceries you know
and then made it to the NBA and and
Patrick has been everywhere and they
have that same thing they both believe
everybody wronged them they have tip on
the shoulders about everything and
everybody every day and that's what
makes Patrick Beverley take but I love
it when you when you go against the
Lakers like he doesn't care
you know if it's LeBron or anybody like
his attitude is I don't care and you
know I don't know how you use that as a
coach to let it sort of permeate the
rest of the team or if you want that to
happen and you know sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't but obviously put
him on the Brawn was was thought about
and and we felt like it could be to our
benefit if we have some success that it
you know because the entire team sees
Patrick Beverley guarding LeBron James
that doesn't sound like it makes a lot
of sense but it did the brother you're
gonna have a great game most likely no
matter who guards them anyway you know
you can look at it that way but if you
have any little bit of success and with
Patrick you know it's huge I thought it
was good for our team yeah it was fun to
watch but you know the Clippers have
dominated the Lakers in the last couple
of years but do you still feel like
there's that inferiority complex or chip
on you know the shoulders of the
Clippers when it comes to the Lakers in
town
I don't know I mean listen it's the
Lakers and the Lakers are in LA they've
been in our land they've won titles in
LA so to say they have my head start it
would be an understatement but you know
this team and then the teams in the past
they do look at the Lakers as a rivalry
and somebody they want to be and you
know we we've been very over the last
five years we've been extremely
successful against them which makes you
feel good now this won't doubt about it
I don't know what else it does so bad to
be honest it just makes you feel good
you stock Rivers joining us Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
I love what you did with Dirk Nowitzki
and now you didn't do that with Dwyane
Wade you were winning one of the games
and losing the other one were you I said
man if you had to play a little worse
[Laughter]
way that like six threes they came in an
Isetta the post game down the stretch
what made you think in that month or did
you just think in that moment let me
stop the game with whatever ten seconds
to go just so this crowd can say goodbye
to dirt I was standing near midcourt and
I swear I'd look out on the floor and I
see dirt standing there oh the games
decided there's nine ten seconds left
and I turn he grabbed a mic I had no
idea what I was going to say what I was
going to do and I didn't know it just
worked out like I did you know usually
you call the timeout both teams go to
the hot over I grab the mic and you know
implored the crowd you know to cheer for
their he deserves he's such a grievance
such a great ambassador for the lead you
know what I thought would recur laut did
was let them stay out on the floor and
so you think about it nobody ever went
to their Huddle's everyone stayed out on
the floor
and I thought that really helps so you
know it was one of those things there
was spontaneous and worked and and I'm
just so happy that it worked for there
because I thought he deserved it
what do you think Dirk's impact on how
we look at the big man or how the big
man plays you know when we look back on
Dirk Nowitzki what kind of impact do you
think he had on seven-footers or guys
who were that big going outside I say
look at the game you know there's been
two players to me over the last 3040
years that have really changed the way
the game is played by Magic Johnson
yeah made every big guy think he could
be a guard and then dirt took it further
he made every big I think you could
shoot and so now when you watch the game
it there's no team that doesn't have a
four that stretches the floor I don't
think there's one team you can say that
about everything has one or they're
willing to put their three at the four
and a lot of that is due to dirt I also
look at Steph Curry I think Steph Curry
may have the biggest impact on the NBA
because all of these young you know kids
who were six foot six two six one like
everybody feels like they can play the
game I'm not seven feet I can't play the
game like Dirk Nowitzki I can't jump
like Jordan does I can't play the game
but these kids it feels like everybody
wants to be the next Steph Curry what do
you think of that I agree I think he's
the one now you know him and James
Harden a little bit but I would say more
courage because when you look at courage
size you know first of all he's bigger
than everyone thinks you know I think I
think a lot of people look at curry
because he's not you know you don't see
the muscles they think he's like this
6-foot guard he's actually about to
force inside but the way he shoots the
ball and the distance he shoots the ball
and also it's borne wings and like his
ball handling is flashy and amazing I
think those two things with his size it
allows every player you go to a you
games you never know you go to a you
guys 10 years ago what was everyone
doing doing halftime or before the game
is donkey now he's going to an APU gang
no one's dunking everyone started behind
the tree
because they know that's what they have
to do have you ever had a player when's
the last time a player said something to
you like trash talk you as the head
coach of the Clippers during again for
another day yeah
oh well during my dream probably does is
every time we play what's he say to you
because we have we have this running
thing it started you know we're I still
I'm proud that we are the last team to
become state in the West and if you
remember that series dream on and I got
into it they beat us in game 1 and in
game 2 Lakes was having a big game and I
I started which I never do I looked at
dream on I said there'll be no whining
tonight and then he got upset and so he
started calling me Glenn you're not
worthy of doc he's going to your given
name call him Jamal that's his middle
name yeah dream on Jamal Green I mean
it's not exactly bird or Jordan
trash-talking but you know it's you know
it's sort of with today's game yeah Bert
was ruthless because he would attack
your mental you know even you would make
like three shots in a row and and
bourbon like run by and say oh wow first
quarter
let's see if you can do that in force or
stuff like that to make you think you
know the trash-talking today is pretty
weak but you know cuz bird had a couple
of good games against you guys so you
know he he had some room like he could
say something you you couldn't exactly
say something back to him could you I
mean it's gorgeous it's still my best
the best video that we ever show because
the
and we talked about this when I saw you
in LA when you had those guys on the
bench and they were falling off the
bench Antoine Carr and cliff Levingston
and poor Mike fratello he's trying to
coach and you know birds killing you
guys in Antoine Carr and cliff
Levingston her falling off the bench
like oh my god what are we witnessing
here I told you was brutal it was brutal
that next stage so that's all Mike show
it is so bird store and he showed our
guys on the bench thank God he didn't
have a telestrator that would have been
that would have been awful did Dominique
talk trash at all yeah yeah it was a
good trash talker but it was more about
you know it's you know obviously offense
and you couldn't guard him you know he
had this thing about jumping like he
used to say everyone can get to the top
floor but there a few people can get to
the penthouse and he would say that all
day you know I can jump to the penthouse
and I that's true better than him oh no
one no one in our era if you looked at
some of the dunks he did show dunks in
the middle and to end of games you know
he's won a game against Milwaukee I
still think he's one of the greatest
don't ever it was a game winning so dumb
you know he double pumped and don't dunk
over I said 50 microts that wins a game
you don't ever see that and that was
dominate he could jump better than
Jordan you know there are different
jumpers because Jordan was a 1 foot
jumper so I think if you were looking at
it it was prettier to watch Michael jump
it was more violent with Dominique chess
he's one of the greatest two-foot
jumpers to ever play the game now it's
the one for jumpers look better because
they stay in the air longer but the
dominate of two feet was amazing hey Doc
Congrats on the season so far the team
is fun to watch you know you just make
me stay up too late to watch him so but
it's worth it they're fun that's a young
team man you got a
about 20 21 year old guys out there
starting for you oh yeah we got three
guys you know three rookies starting
right now and for the most part with our
three guys under 21 you know it's
awesome they're great kids and you would
love them they're all just they want to
learn they want to get better and they
play hard that's all you could ask for
Thank You doc we appreciate your time as
always right
that's uh doc rivers Continental Tire
Coaches Corner for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]